what's the deal with airplane
peanuts these are 10 of the most
shocking reveals by comedians on are you
[Applause]
garbage starting off with Mark Norman
you nibble in the grocery store oh yeah
that's what the whole produce is for
yeah he's a known Thief not to mention
the hot bar that hot bar doesn't stand a
chance with these Sticky
Fingers you can just put like chicken
and pasta in the bowl and you just eat
eating and
shopping yeah no you're not you're not
do that that's what Whole Foods is I go
in there I eat a cup of soup I
leave I thought everybody did that uh
you and other homeless people I'm sure
yeah all right well they keep the eye on
the hobos and I'm sitting pretty just
wear a nice shirt nobody says a thing I
got a mouth full of chicken noodle
anyone in your family rep Ever represent
themselves in court no but my dad
somebody had tried or thought about it
so I was getting uh my friend got
arrested for we were I was driving we
were driving past the cop and he
screamed he was like Pig yeah they don't
like that and he caught us and he tried
to he pulled me out of the car he didn't
pull me out he made me come out of the
car and he was like what' you say and I
was like I didn't say it he was like who
did I was like I'm not going to tell I
was like I can't snitch on my friend no
R he was like well it came from your
side of the car and I was like yeah and
it wasn't me do the math here come on
dude not telling you but it wasn't me
and then uh we went to court and he
brought you in for that Court dude what
what was the charge I obstructing he was
pulling someone over ah [__] but in
the trumped up charges it was crazy and
then in the middle of it my dad stood up
said something and the judge I guess he
knew the judge somehow I don't know
[__] Larry he go he said something
and the judge like jokingly was like are
you are you his attorney and my dad goes
no but I did stay at a holiday in
express last night shut the [__] Place
went wild
dude [__] way it's
unbelievable all right you guys get out
of
here was a Target it's an Impulse buy
God damn it you guys got me [__] this
is the question know who wasn't at
Target making impulse buys the [__]
Kennedy okay
yeah Jesus Christ I hate him I hate him
it is a brown egg though it's an organic
organic range there isn't a more fun guy
disgusting all right breaking the fourth
wall he walked in a suit and I [__]
chubbed up I'm like this guy's [__]
came to play Jesus well I can cross you
ever eaten a hard B EG public off the
list on camera we should have good
god oh you
stink in a long long time were you pee
in the shower I used to I used to [__]
in the shower too for yeah a nice little
dump in there you pick it up with your
hand and just flip it in the toilet in
the morning kill two birds with one
stone but that was a long time ago that
was when I was killing animal oh that's
the first yeah here on the program
ladies and
gentlemen you want the truth I got to
give it to you of course we appreciate
that make me come over a ferry to come
here and blow lies at your [__] [__]
sucker if I got on that F I'm going to
make it worth a while here's some dirt
bag [__] about me she is in my life
never seen any of the Godfathers I've
never seen the Godfathers and I've never
eaten a pork chop or had goat cheese in
my whole life I don't know if that makes
me garbage I [__] is wrong with you
makes you a wacko for sure
why I don't know your next question but
I never had a BK chop yeah yeah I don't
know what find a c kind of I don't know
I just how do you not have a pork chop I
honestly might say I don't think I've
ever had a pork chop either I've never
pork chop I'm a very weird eater pork
chops and applesauce sourkraut [__] yeah
no applesauce had applesauce I used to
eat Ms applesauce out of the jar with my
hands
yeah I a't going to help I wasai till
the hands recently and my go-to uh kind
of yeah well cuz my daughter I've eaten
it yeah because applesauce makes a
comeback when you have a kid cuz you
know forget cuz now it's like dipping
the macaroni and cheese in the
applesauce is like that's what we do a
lot of my friends are not getting
married and a lot of them have gotten
married and it's already failed okay uh
let's just say it's a friend from high
school a cousin not not like you know
Ben or something like somebody kind of
but whatever yeah what's in that
envelope what are you
given
oh interesting maybe a grand
whoa I didn't want to know what you gave
the kid what you gave the producer Ben
got a lot of money really yeah I would
never get the ideas [__] I would never I
would never say what he got of course
yeah we wouldn't ask you know 50,000 I
gave him $50,000 literally I gave him I
gave him 50 grand tax free seriously we
we structured it so as taxfree 50 Grand
what like 15 over the next three years
no 50 Grand just I like we structured it
so as a bonus without taxes my business
manager did it holy [__] wow 50 jees
[__] Dylan playing ball I love
him and he's great he's my family but
you know does that like I said I
wouldn't never say the
number it was I wouldn't say the number
does that get around the wedding you
noticed that maybe a half hour 45
minutes deal I'm sick of giving people
[__] and not talking about it you know
what I mean I'm a little sick of it so
maybe you'll get around
now are you garbage what are you get do
I got a $1,500 here's a question are you
garbage do you give your best friend a
present and then talk about it on a
popular podcast in hopes that other
people hear it also that's a good
question you structured it as a bonus I
love that let me talk to my guy it's a
bonus um godamn damn a jihad's good a
thousand's good wow is that a hug is
that a hug when he finds out yeah he's
autistic but it's it's a hug you know
holy [__] man plus keeping the tax man
out of it I even like that too why let
them with
their In fairness they got me a book
about
spiders what would be the most if if it
sticks out that you ever spent on a meal
uh I don't know if you want me to tell
you we do I want you want to write it
down like a rich guy write it down yes
I'm I'm GNA read it out loud 100% going
to read it out
loud it wasn't long ago oh yeah take
that one there you go it's this was a
this is a first finally I got pretty
elaborate dinner I had okay throw a
credit card number down there too just a
maybe a finsky if you got it on you also
how much cash do you have on you right
now uh I don't know know okay let me to
count what the [__] let me say it yeah
give me it how many people were there
it's just
you it was uh ladies and
gentlemen it was a group it was a group
of us but I mean what
city Chicago can I say what the number
is I mean you think we should this
honestly this is what people tune in for
all right sure 52,000
it was my birthday that's more than I
made last year on the
books no yeah that's your birthday of
course blow it the [__] out is that with
tip that was with tip all right with tip
what's 5% of 52,000 I fig it with wine
and tax it's really only 38 Grand holy
[__] uh say you go out to a restaurant
with the with friends right say you and
S stino or so going out to a nice dind I
have a thing who's picking up that check
well Santino and I'm going to say I'm
going to start a war and he's going to
be so mad but he I'm beginning to think
let's he disappear uh I want to say that
the last meals he disappears really so
right before the check appears he goes I
got a golf thing or you know I mean oh
[__] I got to go to Dave was like you
didn't say you were going to shoot today
right there's something and then he
leaves and then the check comes and it's
happened for the last eight times and
and I I've never said it out out before
I don't know if that's going to start
something with him he's paid before I
remember call I'm sure I'm sure you but
the last couple a nice guy really great
I love him very talented guy but the
last couple has been uh a little suspect
but you know I'm going to wait for the
next meal see what happens you know and
they and let me say the last one was
maestros have you heard of maos it's a
very expensive restaurant chain I think
I spent I'll just tell you what I spent
cuz it was with the producer Andrew and
a girl named jety who's like a sidekick
on bad friends very talented girl she
had never been to a fancy restaurant so
we took to Maestro and I I think I
dropped
$750 and he left really right and it
kind of you know it kind of irked me a
bit you know I'm now expressing that and
don't edit that out I want to see what
that happens for a relationship edit
that out it's the clip what are you
talking about yeah yeah I want to see
what that happens for I got say he's not
cheap he's been he saved my life a bunch
of times and I love keep put this in the
clip too keep this in the clip too he's
a great guy right but I'm just saying
last couple times that's all I mean I I
got to say this I got to call B I love
you I got to call BRS and Strikes here
750 bucks we dropped that yeah you got
to be dropping you Kidd me dinner know
your I know a nice restaurant you think
I should be paying for it um that that's
a haircut to you guys who gives a [__]
that's getting coffee you come in here
all that that's where you hit me with
750 I got Tom sigura back here with a
$52,000 check not including wait wait
wait wait that's his check that's what
he spent on his uh his birthday dinner
750 I got that
on I'll pay it for San Andy I got you
kid is it a big house I just built it
177,000
[Applause]
ft that's a big house there you go you
live in New York or anything
big we all live
here [__] a 10 is bigger than I'm
I 177,000 Square ft and I did it I you
know I didn't High contract him my
husband like you're crazy I saved the
cash I did the budget and I said this is
what I want so I'm old school so I
didn't do any of that vinyl stuff I did
it in the basement but I definitely
didn't do it upstairs up the the first
two levels is all wood it's all hard
wood is there a third level yes 17,000
square ft if it wasn't it be the size of
the [__] weight house yeah it's it's
all do you have an elevator I do shut up
no you
don't what holy sh a home elevator is
not that
expensive it's not that cheap either not
cheap
either holy [__] okay you're the first
you're the first person to have an
elevator on the show I'm okay so I'm 51
and I don't like stairs cuz I'm fat my
hband fat my kids fat everybody
fat so what about uh in the in the
bedroom there you sleep with your socks
on no what are you sleep in crazy I'm a
boxers guy just box
sometimes I'll go fully nude sometimes
fresh out the shower clean sheets I'm
rubbing my little my little fresh nuts
all over that are those sheets clean I I
at most I'll go two weeks without how do
you do the laundry or you drop it off a
drop off yeah I'm I'm stunned and
impressed two weeks two weeks tops good
for you sometimes I'll switch them out I
would go 18 months if I didn't have a
wife yeah I would I don't think I would
ever it's bad here's here's class here's
here's new money class the reason it's
two weeks is because we get a [__]
cleaning lady and she does them every
two weeks she does them yeah I I will if
I want to I'll do them you know once if
there's been a particular if there's
been a couple incidents yeah yeah yeah
if we've got a couple squirters over you
know it's like maybe one day I'll enjoy
a little hint of [__] sheets but like
after that you got to change couple of
squ wait hold on the cleaning lady's
doing the laundry what do you have a
washer and dryer in the building I no no
I set out the clean sheets and she'll
change she changes them that's wow
that's like rich guy [__] that's what I
picture like but aesome dude yeah
exactly so does every pillow in your
bedroom have a pillowcase on it it does
wow I am stunned by that it does come I
I pictured you on a single mattress no
sheets on the floor seven years ago you
know six years ago for sure I do a thing
called private Suite oh this guy's got
it all private Suite you so it's a
separate entrance to the airport so the
airport this is what I've heard you talk
about this airport own [__] airport
here right and then the all the all the
business is here check in and all that
is on the left sure private Suite is its
own little entity off to the the other
side of the airport so you pull in valet
like you're it's it's it's it looks like
you're pulling into a uh like to a very
private restaurant uh they they greet
you at the car they take you to a room
the room is filled with what you you
tell them what you want they know me so
they always have Tios they always have
wine they have snacks candies they bring
in they have a menu you can order from
they bring always bring in caviar and
champagne to greet you caviar get there
I'm so sorry we've had so many people on
the show you're the first person who has
an airport Rider that is [__] sick is
it connected to an airline uh no so so
you go to it's the airport yeah it's
it's it's so you go to like you said
he's not these bums that we normally
have Peter how [__] insane is it it's
[__] insane it's the coolest thing
you ever do if you want to smoke cigars
or or whatever they have an outdoor one
that's attached to an outdoor SS at the
airport my daughter was turned uh 15 and
she had her birthday and we were I was
doing Atlantic City so I brought the
girls to Atlantic City they each brought
two friends what a flex and I brought
all of them into the private suite and
they had a birthday cake for Isa there
and all her friends were like what the
[__] is this then you get they that
how'd that make you feel oh like a
gangster anytime any I don't have no
problem spending money to void anxiety
or to treat my kids I have a hard time
spending money on myself like cars and
stuff like that I'm not that kind of guy
you control all the finances I don't
know about control because he buys a lot
of [__] without my knowledge or
permission two Rolexes on wait a minute
I didn't even see
that new money trash and I'm here for it
he's Bouie BT I love it I feel like
they're both wrong yeah they're probably
two different time zones one of those
definitely isn't set to Daylight savings
neither of them are wait how did I not
see that you walked in with two watches
on yeah so clearly you got two watches
you showed up late
today what the [__] let's get this guy a
third watch please
Peter joke
world that's it joke
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out